accueillir tout
alors voyons voir en 2d d'arc est ce
qu'on à la télévision c'est l'heure du
bilan c'est le bilan c'est l'heure du
bilan est frère tahiti maquillés par
bernard montiel
ouais c'est vrai ça dure une demi-heure
de mclean et ron très très chaud
j'assure yolette jeu de revenir de 2-4
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé sur
j'aime bien ça te va bien mais une
nouvelle mention assez bien alors c'est
la fin d'année lors du bilan je vais
donc récompenser le meilleur et le pire
de touche pas à mon poste
au début je voulais récompenser le
chroniqueur qui avait le plus d'infos
médias le problème c'est que les
dernières infos média quatre journées de
mort j'ai envie de pitbull est alors ici
on est bien meilleur aux vans et donc
pour la meilleure veine de 2019 les
nommés sont à
jean michel mr alias le mathématicien
devrait une calculette sur le téléphone
ouvrez-la jeu très rapide en calcul
mental une 222 way plus 1347 1205 1 340
j'ai dit que j'étais rapide je venais
que j'étais bon matthieu delormeau pour
une nouvelle preuve d'amour envers
benjamin castaldi
hardyson disons 10 euros alors je vous
dis oui
que reste-t-il à castaldi a précédé
force et cyril hanouna plus connu sous
le nom du thar baba ya un micro trottoir
pour savoir ce qu'était la rate
c'est indispensable bah c'est un petit
peu comme vous dans l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on essaie de nous brest est de 12 alors
quand je fais les courses dans mon
magasin bio je me dis qu'en voyant les
têtes des clients vaut mieux manger des
ogm mais on dit pas qui en a car si vous
voulez moi comme vous avez pas assumé
jusqu'au phare mais je n'ai pas su mais
vous qui a la main j'aime bien jour nous
suggérons à qui vous vous vous jean-mi
la justice vous allez j'avoue que c'est
une vraie blague de connard mais j'ai
promis
cyril hormis les deux fois michel aussi
assez vous si vous jean mi j'ai envie
que nous j'ai envie de voisinage aurait
duré 10 jours mais il était très déçu
ouais vraiment pas bien arriver à rester
calmes merci merci avait estimé
franchement c'est violent c'est plutôt
non sa récompense et cyril ceux qui
paient sans marquer quoi ah bon mais
c'est pas moi qui récompensait si vous
deviez choisir
la réparer les six mois de sa vie c'est
un rêve y en a quand même prévenu un
arrêt longtemps qu'on n'était pas venu
le jour ghana replay d'ailleurs ce soir
vous êtes très très beau lot de fans et
c'est pas toujours apprécié ah ouais
ouais enfin le stylisme l'aviation en
tout cas merci en tout cas votre avis ne
compte pas c'est que son palmarès voilà
on parle souvent d'une séquence ça
s'appelle le zumba bas je vous rappelle
que c'est quand on souffle sur votre
tête cyril pour comprendre immédiatement
ce que vous pensez ouais alors à vous de
désigner le meilleur zumba 2019
ah ouais ouais cyril hanouna
quand il croit que julien courbet se
grattent les testicules en direct alors
que c'est laurent baffie qui lui demande
il t'a des pieds et avait donné des
conseils pour la suite de ta carrière
oui alors greg guillotin effectivement
[Applaudissements]
cyril hanouna combien et mathieu se met
à chanter sans prévenir personne
et donc j'ai interprété monsieur
aznavour jezebel
c'est ça ta mais interprété une juin
titre 2-2 charlène nokia et cyril
hanouna
quand il découvre que pied de bélie et
la nouvelle bertrand renard à 16 m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est insupportable
franchement je crois que pour tout le
monde là à la voir
je peux regarder bien ma tête je suis
vraiment choqué je crois que c'est une
voix de l'autre je pense c'est une donne
au delà mais non mais non ça vient de là
bas non mais alémanique
[Musique]
la blonde est ce que tu as dit pas si
con la blonde est non et passif moi j'ai
déjà dit ce que j'ai fait ce que j'avais
déjà attaqué ne faut pas être choqué le
prochain mais c'est pas parce que mon
père c'est moi et moi je n'avais pas
c'est ça oui
triple en entrevue on s'extasie pascale
racine carrée alors vous collez vous la
connaissez vous la casse et racine
carrée de même à 2-2 alors la santé
notamment titoff
oui c'est cette voie là dans ton cul
ah là là là on est en train de
s'extasier que vous m'ayez poser la
question de penser je n'aurais tu pas la
réponse
c'était une insulte le groupe à bail à
ferme et c'est beau mais bon vous avez
vu les scores qu'on a fait quand vous
n'étiez pas là donc si j'étais vous
[Applaudissements]
l'affecté record d'audience bien une
ascèse on va mettre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors bonne ambiance je pense que ça va
le calmer
3 et michel merci la ceinture là allez
on y va on est balancé en fait un modèle
pour la jeunesse française soit
professionnellement ou vestimentaire par
mois parlant bien sûr parce que personne
ne porte que le combo veste costumes
survêtement kata qui nie que vous
personne mais personne alors tout le
monde veut vous ressembler et même à
l'international
après vous avez des cerisiers dans le
monde entier alors femmes et le cas vu
là des sosies cas fort boyard pour le
meilleur sosie cyril hanouna les nommer
ah ouais ouais je les connais
cyril hanouna dans une série qui
cartonne en algérie
cyril hanouna qui présente sa toute
nouvelle chorégraphie de noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et s'il hanouna qui a débuté sa carrière
dans rex
et bien moi ça
voir quoi li la plaque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas prendre le risque parler
de faire baisser l'audience où les trois
yable le incroyable aussi pour l'été le
mans - le 3 1 pour chaque époque alors
préfet on sait que tout le budget ne
passe pas dans les salaires pourquoi
parce qu'il passe dans le tarn et eric
et les costumes c'est la priorité de
chaque début de saison vous connaissez
un coût nécessaire et ses imitateurs qui
sont obligés de dire qu'ils imitent si
l'on reconnaît pas la personne portables
et bien pour le déguisement c'est pareil
ici mais malgré tout il y en a certains
qui à qui tout va
mathieu award du meilleur déguisement
dénommé son
dalida castaldi
[Musique]
les dents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
valérie bénaïm en syrie d'hanouna vérité
ça c'est vrai et fabien lecoeuvre
complètement bluffant en sliman
dans la vie on sait tous
c'est
paris
ça vient
franchement
photo y a pas photo c'est fabien
lecoeuvre bravo tu as trouvé ton rôle
toi c'est vrai captain igloo be missed
personnes hier en venant me captain
igloo miss l'imam ont fait d'accord
alors dernière fois du foot là à ce que
hier bizarrement vous n'étiez pas là
mais à moi y avait des matchs de foot à
19h à bas coûts en santé pour un match
de merde c'était à bonal un salon plus
annonce le jep à la chaîne mais bon et
là bas la chaîne n'aurait pas vu le
niger je dormais une photo de monde et
vous êtes obligé pas eu justement quoi
banon était pas votre mais la faute au
pied bon alors avant de connaître de
tabac de beneath 9a dernier trophée ce
que je préfère pourquoi parce que j'aime
touche pas à mon poste parce que c'est
la seule émission où on voit des
chroniqueurs se frapper non bien encore
c'est la seule édition voit le patron
frappé c'est kronach la seule émission
on voit la ministre est encore là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous allez donc choisir c'est la
seule émission où les chroniqueurs
attaque le panneau nord-est vous avez vu
d'autres émissions au love pas qu'on se
fait frapper par les chroniqueurs été
obligé de se défendre nombre est joli
nom n'avait pas vu ça vous allez tout
choisir donc la meilleure bagarre de tpm
p je vous rassure personne n'a été
blessé dans cette séquence au jamaica
stade
[Rires]
cyril hanouna versus matthieu delormeau
qui nous a fait croire que c'était un
loubard mais ça a duré cinq secondes
je tiens à baisser les yeux quand tu me
parles pas vous l'expliquer
matthieu delormeau versus isabelle
morini-bosc spécialiste de panna cotta
et de mawashi geri
et benjamin castaldi versus cyril
hanouna qui s'est pris pour ivan drago
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
pendant de ma volonté mais ça va
peut-être là qu'il va donner jeudi pas
du tout alors c'est dégueulasse parce
que vous avez vous arrêté la séquence au
moment où je retourne la situation de la
mandataire partirai pas vraiment toi on
va donc tout faire le montage enquête
récemment sa première avec isabelle
cours pour moi c'est vraiment au label
mythique sélection des spasmes
on peut pas le voir isabelle ballon
touareg zabel c'est exceptionnel
regarder
je
talent dans la rate d'ailleurs la rate
qu'est ce que c'est ça sert à rien mais
c'est indispensable là vous êtes là
juste après la pub qui a tenu en haleine
toute la france avec cédric le tabac
tout de suite la musique de suspense bah
oui bien longtemps et il est temps de
connaître donc le tabac 2010 note celui
qui a été le seul qu'elle pousse tacler
ses collègues au cours de l'année alors
on appelle un suspense comme ça depuis
le jour on a appris que luke skywalker
était le fils de dark vador qui est
arabe à 2019 with the stars baba of tout
à ausone nineteen j'espère baba
[Musique]
j'attendais tout faits s'étaient
branchés
thierry baumann thierry baumann qui m'a
monté tous les votes pour vous alors si
di romagna sans bien sûr et attention
bielak vers cette vanne non j'adore
thierry baumann tiens c'est vrai il y
avait 200 la connectique on arrive à
darwin rouler la terre cette panne
j'adore cette ville je peux la refaire
si vous avez regardé hier je disais vous
un peu s'il vous plaît merci
est ce que vous voulez dire qu'est ce
qu'il a dit on loge tout à l'heure ouais
est-ce qu'on a 10 ans lofteurs parce que
je le dis aux téléspectateurs que maddie
en loge tout à l'heure alors mois ferme
ta gueule c'est qu'on a tous les trois
la même passion qui nous anime
vous parlez donnant la main bien sûr à
des mariages comme toi ou dans un rêve
je raconte un truc et vous m'avez dit
texto dans le rêve tu t'es cru cette
année à santa gueule du monde doit avoir
foncé très bien où était-ce doit tout le
week end
merci qu'est ce qu'elle veut ce qui est
incroyable quand on regarde la pieuvre
et c'est qu'il ya treize prix nobel qui
ont étudié des choses dans la mer sont
pas là je sais faire un petit qui
chantent mais nous espérons nous et
faire la pie qui sort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fashion agression à dire au t4 est
ce que parce qu'aujourd'hui il l'aura du
rire il y aura de l'émotion il y aura
les cadeaux il y aura des gens qu'on
reverra peut-être plus c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce que tu as quelque
chose à dire aux téléspectateurs dans ta
dernière voilà au moins dernière blague
et reviendra en janvier
toi oui mais ce qui est cool c'est que
ben je pensais pas quand j'ai commencé
2009 faire une chronique tu t'es
tranquille avec benjamin castaldi une
fois par semaine à rigoler et puis après
deux mois et propose de venir une fois
je me suis c'est très bien ça durera
qu'une fois tu vas me dire et comme tout
le monde
finalement non je suis restée toute
l'année et tu m'as un petit peu viré en
début d'année mais je suis revenu et
parce que j'ai l'oeil du tigre et je
lâche pas et je serai toujours là et
tant que tu dois tout à côté de toi un
petit peu je viendrai faire le sera de
rigaud tu seras toujours là bien sûr un
ton coeur et franchement cartonne foulée
et bravo
[Applaudissements]